Noah Williams: Today’s focus: payments retry strategy.
Noah Williams: Any blockers from last time?
Noah Williams: Let’s aim for a concrete owner and rollout plan.
Priya Singh: Action: book design review.
Riley Chen: I propose we split payments retry strategy into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: My take is we split payments retry strategy into two subtasks.
Jordan Patel: From QA perspective, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Priya Singh: Action: book design review.
Samira López: Let’s not block on payments retry strategy; ship a thin slice.
Avery Kim: Let’s not block on payments retry strategy; start with a spike.
Priya Singh: Risk: scope creep for payments retry strategy.
Noah Williams: From design side, We need to align with capacity.
Avery Kim: I propose we split payments retry strategy into two subtasks.
Riley Chen: From QA perspective, Performance baseline needs to be recorded.
Priya Singh: Let’s not block on payments retry strategy; parallelize testing.
Riley Chen: Any risks we’re missing? on payments retry strategy.
Noah Williams: Let’s not block on payments retry strategy; parallelize testing.
Samira López: Infra-wise, Specifically for payments retry strategy.
Noah Williams: Quick update on the scope on payments retry strategy.
Jordan Patel: From QA perspective, Design feedback is pending.
Jordan Patel: Let’s not block on payments retry strategy; start with a spike.
Riley Chen: Infra-wise, Design feedback is pending.
Priya Singh: My take is we split payments retry strategy into two subtasks.
Avery Kim: We need to timebox the spike on payments retry strategy.
Jordan Patel: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on payments retry strategy.
Jordan Patel: Action: write migration.
Jordan Patel: Risk: scope creep for payments retry strategy.
Samira López: Risk: data migration for payments retry strategy.
Riley Chen: Risk: flaky tests for payments retry strategy.
Jordan Patel: I propose we split payments retry strategy into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: We should add a feature flag on payments retry strategy.
Samira López: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on payments retry strategy.
Riley Chen: Let’s not block on payments retry strategy; start with a spike.
Jordan Patel: We need to timebox the spike on payments retry strategy.
Noah Williams: Coordinate with SRE for rollout on payments retry strategy.
Avery Kim: Action: create test plan.
Avery Kim: Any risks we’re missing? on payments retry strategy.
Avery Kim: From QA perspective, Design feedback is pending.
Riley Chen: Risk: accessibility gaps for payments retry strategy.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for payments retry strategy.
Samira López: Action: book design review.
Riley Chen: Risk: accessibility gaps for payments retry strategy.
Jordan Patel: My take is we split payments retry strategy into two subtasks.
Noah Williams: From design side, We might need a migration.
Noah Williams: Let’s clarify acceptance criteria on payments retry strategy.
Riley Chen: I think we split payments retry strategy into two subtasks.
Priya Singh: Risk: accessibility gaps for payments retry strategy.
Jordan Patel: Infra-wise, We will stage it behind a feature flag.
Avery Kim: Risk: data migration for payments retry strategy.
Priya Singh: Action: create test plan.
Samira López: Action: book design review.
Jordan Patel: Okay, who can take ownership?
Samira López: Let’s finalize target date in Jira after this.
Priya Singh: We’ll review outcomes in the next standup.